el lanzamiento de misiles balísticos
desde un tren en corea del norte la
prueba exitosa de corea del sur con un
misil lanzado desde un submarino y
australia anunciando la compra sin
precedentes de submarinos de propulsión
nuclear todo en una misma semana son los
más recientes ejemplos de una carrera
armamentística e intensificada en la
región asia-pacífico
el certamen de newham es extraordinario
que no tengas nada más y nada menos que
a las dos coreas ensayando misiles el
mismo día eso habla de la carrera
militar que hay en esta región y a la
que todos deben prestarle atención a
quienes rigen de aragón inspección
chinche o el año pasado asia y oceanía
gastaron más de medio billón de dólares
en sus ejércitos según el instituto
internacional de estudios para la paz de
estocolmo mientras el avance de corea
del norte se lleva a los titulares las
naciones vecinas también están
almacenando armas los gastos en defensa
de australia india japón y corea del
norte están al alza un 20 por ciento de
esto corresponde a la adquisición de
activos marítimos de disuasión de largo
alcance muchos analistas creen que esto
es una reacción directa al poderío
militar de china beijing actualmente
invierte un estimado de 252 mil millones
de dólares al año en defensa por su
parte china culpa a eeuu de disparar los
gastos militares en la región y acusa a
washington de ayudar activamente a los
aliados regionales para reforzar sus
arsenales y disuadir la creciente
capacidad militar de ser el más reciente
ejemplo es el anuncio de eeuu sobre su
ayuda a australia para construir
submarinos de propulsión nuclear bajo el
nuevo pacto de defensa de eeuu parece
interesado en empoderar a sus aliados
con asistencia técnica y con maneras que
antes los australianos sólo podían
imaginar rainbows atrapadas entre china
y eeuu las naciones del indo pacífico
que antes estaban al margen ahora están
adquiriendo más arsenal muchos analistas
temen que la proliferación de misiles
incremente las tensiones dispare la
carrera armamentística y pueda conllevar
a una guerra